es ist eine der rätselhaftesten
explosionen im weltraum denn diese
explosion bricht alle rekorde
nicht nur dass die supernova etf 14-mal
es 2014 mit einem nachleuchten von mehr
als 600 tagen mehr als zehn mal länger
dauert als normal
sie hat auch einen mysteriösen vorgänge
rund um den zu finden müssen wir in das
jahr 1954 zurück wie ist die lage also
bei etf 14 teil es jetzt den klick zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
das ist eine wirklich verrückte
geschichte denn bei etf 14h es stimmt
einfach gar nichts im lask umriss
observatorien kalifornien wurde die 800
millionen lichtjahre entfernte supernova
entdeckt sie explodierte
mit einem für supernovae typ 2 p
typischen aufleuchten aber dann
passierte etwas das eigentlich unmöglich
ist normalerweise passiert bei diesem
supernovae folgendes sie haben vor der
explosion eine geschätzte 8 bis 17 fache
sonnenmasse beziehungsweise eine bis zu
32 fache aber dann kommt es sich nicht
so super nova sondern die sterne stürzen
zu einem schwarzen loch zusammen
es sind rote überriesen oder selten auch
gelbe überriesen die zu solchen
supernovae werden oder eben auch zu
schwarzen löchern sie kollabieren immer
auf die gleiche art und weise wenn sie
nicht so groß sind der brennstoff für
ihre kernfusion ist aufgebraucht und
ohne diese fusion können sie der
gravitation durch die eigene masse
keinen gegend rum entgegensetzen die
kreation ist dann so stark dass der
stern in sich zusammenstürzt das heißt
dass die durch die relativitätstheorie
beschriebene krümmung der raumzeit denn
das ist die gravitation zum
zusammensturz führt die masse sturz
aufeinander und stößt bei diesem
aufprall wie beim zusammenstoß bei dem
unfall wieder auseinander
diese explosion sehen wir als supernova
was übrig bleibt ist ein neutronenstern
durchmesser zehn bis zwanzig kilometer
also winzig klein
der rückstoß der materie führt zum
aufleuchten der gase rund um diesen
neutronenstern für rund 100 tage bei etf
14h es dauerte es allerdings 600 tage
diese supernova stellt absolut alles auf
den kopf was die astrophysik bisher über
diese supernovae wusste und es wird noch
schmackhafter die helligkeit der
explosion änderte sich in den letzten
jahren ständig immer wieder wurde die
supernova heller und dunkler etwas
absolut unmöglich ist und es wird noch
verrückter diese supernova ist quasi ein
déjà vu denn 1954 cup ist sie schon mal
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
entdeckten damals an genau derselben
stelle eine supernova und das ist
absolut verrückt wie kann das sein
ein stern der mehrmals stirbt es scheint
nur eine erklärung dafür zu geben
dieser stern ist ein dinosaurier ein
stern den es so eigentlich nicht mehr
geben dürfte
solche sterne dürften nur in der
frühzeit des universums existiert haben
sie sind mit bis zu 130 sonnenmassen
absolut riesig und können dadurch
mehrmals explodieren ihr kern bleibt
lange unbeschädigt und sie kollabieren
erst nach mehreren explosionen zu
schwarzen löchern vielleicht werden wir
hier jetzt zeuge der entstehung eines
solchen schwarzen loches und sehen
vielleicht in einigen jahren an dieser
stelle gar nichts mehr außer einer
gravitationslinse wie sie schwarze
löcher bilden spannend auf jeden fall
ich halte euch hier auf dem laufenden
wenn er kein video dazu zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann lassen wir
hier ein abo da vergesst nicht dem genau
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
neue gefahr mehr streuende schwarze
löcher absolut spannendes thema einfach
draufklicken dann geht es sofort los und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt